okay now this is not a fake story we are
in the real world here because of
mounting claims that Donald Trump is not
cognitively competent and not fit to
serve as president of the United States
because more and more evidence is out
there that Donald Trump may be in the
early stages of dementia Donald Trump
has now agreed to undergo a medical exam
at Walter Reed Medical Center to I guess
try to put these allegations to rest and
the claims include everything from Trump
doesn't recognize people he's known for
decades - Trump often is repeating the
exact same stories word for word as if
he doesn't even remember having told
that story now these can also be signs
of complete and total narcissism right
but let's put that aside because there's
a lot more that's being added to this
story the problem with this little
medical tests stunt is that the entire
thing is completely and totally bogus
and I'm gonna tell you why right so as
the story goes as told by Trump he's
gonna go to Walter Reed Medical Center
in Washington DC this Friday he's going
to be fully and thoroughly examined by
the same doctor who examined President
Obama it's not gonna be Jacob Bornstein
or whatever the guys name is who said
Harold Bernstein who said Oh Jacob was
his son who said oh this is the fittest
president ever to serve or whatever
it'll be the same guy who looked at
Obama and again it's gonna happen this
week this will be a two-hour test we are
told which according to medical experts
normally would include urine and blood
tests cardiac checks including Trump's
heart as well as questions to Trump
about his sleeping habits and his sex
life and then Trump's going to make the
results public and we will finally know
the truth about Donald Trump's cognitive
state and his fitness to serve right
well no not really
it's up to Trump to choose what gets
released from this test from this
examination it's not the hospital that's
going to release the results Trump will
get it and his office will put together
a summary likely that means bullet
points of whatever Trump and his White
House staffers decide they're going to
publish so right off the bat let's just
imagine for a second Trump does this
test and
the exam turns up that something is up
with Trump's fitness to serve or a
cognitive ability and it doesn't have to
be released because Trump's going to
pick and choose what it is that he tells
us but the bigger issue is that the
concern here is over cognitive issues
not physical mostly this exam on Friday
it's gonna be about physical issues
which gets us to the real question can
cognitive decline be measured
empirically objectively in a structured
two-hour mostly physical exam centered
around things like blood testing and
heart health but David you might say
he's going to be asked questions about
his sleep habits and his sex life that's
not really going to expose early signs
of dementia you need a full psychiatric
evaluation this is a checkup this is
about Trump's prostate and his
cholesterol and the sexual questions are
more than likely to connect whether his
sex life is safe given his heart health
and that type of thing even the
neurological testing that President
Obama's test included when he had it
done by the same doctor that looks at
reflexes looks at pupil dilation doesn't
look at cognitive decline I spend time
regularly with elderly folks who have
moderately advanced cases of Alzheimer's
and even with them if the person is
relatively clever you've got to spend a
lot of time and talk about really deep
issues to realize something is wrong
because they know how to appear to be
more or less with it in short
conversations and this is especially
true because narcissists and
manipulative people people like Trump
they know how to appear to be smart and
super impressive that's what Trump has
done in order to get tens of millions of
people to vote for him in the first
place so if you think that asking Trump
about his sleeping habits is going to
expose dementia if it's even there
absolutely not so this is a total scam
it's a setup to exonerate Trump and
present his defenders with something
that they can point to and say no look
he went and he saw a doctor and he's
fine but this is a physical exam that is
going to be you
used to claim that Trump is cognitively
with it this is this is an exam that
will not be proof one way or the other
it's the wrong type of exam and people
are going to fall for it and that's why
I'm concerned about it pat because even
though this is not actually going to
measure what it is that Trump is trying
to argue he's fine on his followers will
see this and they'll say look he's
totally fine don't worry about I'm sure
that summary will be fantastic right
that's great I pick out will show that
he's the most healthy president of all
time no doubt and his followers will run
with it we may ask for the long-form
version of it now oh no they're not
gonna get it we'll get the long-form
version of this exam as soon as we get
the long-form version of Donald Trump's
tax returns right that it's just not
gonna happen and it is you need to know
in advance that it is a total sham send
me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show we'll take a break and be
back with so much more right after this
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS